DAVID HARDWICK: BetterCloud
recently reached a milestone
where we're currently serving
40,000 customers representing
over 20 million users.
The cloud platform
has helped us grow
by allowing us to focus
on building the software.
We've been adding about
a million users a month
to our system.
And knowing that we're building
on the shoulders of giants
of Google is something that
they've been able to solve.
It's something that we
don't have to worry about.
ALEEM MAWANI: Because of
the Google Cloud Platform,
we could make investments
in our product
first, as opposed
to infrastructure,
and so we could
iterate really quick
on building the right product.
RAFAEL SANCHES: Before
Google Cloud Platform,
we used to run these
scripts on the servers.
We had to do our own backup.
We had to do our own
database replication.
And now with Google
Cloud Platform,
we don't need to because
we use App Engine.
And it has been great
for us because we
don't have to be concerned
with those things
and just focus on our product.
RUDOLF POTUCEK: Our former
solution was in house,
so there was a very large
amount of hardware maintenance
overhead that we had to deal
with that we now no longer have
because Google
takes care of that.
And that allowed us to focus
on the deployment aspects
and on unblocking developers
and getting code to market.
It has taken away a lot
of the worries about how
do I deal with
the infrastructure
and has focused us on the
core of our product, which
is the software that we create.